The world's oldest living thing is a patch
of Mediterranean sea-grass between Spain and
Cyprus.
It is estimated to be 200,000 years old.
Paul McCartney is the only musician who has
topped the charts as a solo artist, in a duo,
in a trio, in a quartet and in a quintet.
Americans eat 500 million pounds of peanut
butter a year, enough to coat the floor of
the Grand Canyon +.
Manchester United is the most hated brand
in Britain and the 7th most hated in the world.
+
When we blush, our stomach lining goes red
too.
90% of the bullets bought by the Ministry
of Defence are used for training purposes.
A lethal dose of caffeine is about 50 double
espressos.
A father hired other gamers to kill his son
in video games, so that he would stop playing
video games and get a life.
Crocodiles can climb trees.
Some pigs suffer from mysophobia, the fear
of mud.
A study in Texas invited people to taste wine
labeled France, California and Texas.
Nearly all the tasters ranked French as the
best, but in fact all three were the exact
same Texan wine.
President Obama's secret-service nickname
is 'Renegade'.
Ronald Reagan's nickname was 'Rawhide', Bill
Clinton's was 'Eagle' and George W. Bush was
known as 'Trailblazer'.
Red Bull was originally called Red Water Buffalo.
Every time he made a cup of coffee, Beethoven
counted out exactly 60 beans to make sure
it was always exactly the same strength.
Areas of the Moon include the Ocean of Storms,
the Marsh of Decay and the Lake of Death.
By law, buskers in Dublin must have a repertoire
of at least 20 songs.
India has almost 155,000 post offices: more
than any country in the world and almost twice
as many as China.